hallo mein name ist supernett bekommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video riad
bereit sind titel eingeblendet heute
schauen wir uns gemeinsam videos
anbieten 0 aufrufe haben und dass es
irgendwie ein acker
sie klicken hier einfach mal auf play
und dem was für eine musik der videofilm
vorgehen können wir schon dass den
worten hammer landschaften dorf die
konditionen einfach mal auf ne klicken
und bin dann schon dass wir ein nettes
video bekommen werden und zwar dieses
video den titel
juni zeigen die man einen truthahn
zubereitet den bonnern deinen kopf und
ich hab mal wieder auf next geklickt der
krise wie debatte kommt ist die 2
die black ops game clever agierte kunden
meine damen und herren das sieht jemand
und machten kritik der medien
ach das nächste video stellt automatisch
ab das ding hochgeht nach oben
unverletzt wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich verstehe ich warum leute so dumm
trainiere nur eine wiederholung machen
so schädlich
wieder ein game slip der keeper schon
drei leute getötet hat jetzt sogar
doppelt sparen wieder eine person
getötet
das glaube ich nicht beurteilen kann
jetzt hat er ihr eine rakete wieder vier
leute
und das war mal weiter
[Musik]
was für eine scheiße jemanden checker im
akw in biel aber wieder da und soll
jahrhundert
das war ein scheiß man ich wunder mich
wirklich gerade nicht mehr wie du diese
videos alle 0 aufrufe haben diese video
hifi blendet ist und mit den vor und
sehen das in diesem video tatsächlich
passiert wirklich einfach rein gar
nichts kein glühwein natural history
museum camp mitleidlos okay wir haben
einen blog mit 0 aufrufe tatsächlich
also wir gehen mal weiter hier leute
gerade in münchen und wien sk der
glühwein oder irgendwie so lockere band
family vor dem hund
[Musik]
haben wir hier gewohnt haben wir hier
wieder familienhund das
ich frage mich ob ich nicht mehr was das
irgendwie alles bedeuten soll getroffen
[Musik]
ich albträume von dover dieses video als
happy birthday man von einwendungen von
happy birthday hier sind sie mit ihrer
mutter hier den wir nur wie hier sehen
wir wirklich mega süß aber ich weiß
nicht wieso man so was auf youtube
hochlädt
er hat die dinge sind dabei die
prävention broadcasters wenn man sehr
häufig aufgebaut
er ist so dumm derzeit die gerade seinen
stream können dann leute einfach darüber
stream diese spieler spielt ihr seinen
gipfel gleichwertig wenn ich null
zuschauer diese videos mit den namen
drei wochen später
da kann ich auf jeden fall länger dran
bleiben
also ich heute sagen die karten in eine
baustelle doch irgendwie während sieben
minuten ich verstehe kein einziges wort
was hier irgendwie von sich gegeben wird
ich klicke auf nexteer befindet sich
jemand in einem forum und zeigt man
einen puren artikel irgendwie macht ihr
denn 100 einstellungen hinter uns so
palmen jetzt ist er wieder im forum
angekommen und dabei den palmen leuten
ich will das video heute gar nicht lange
halten weil die märkte sind ich bin
krank ich schreibe der bachelorarbeit
ich musste gleich wieder an die uni
gehen wollte heute aber einfach nicht
nicht hochladen
deswegen hoffe ich natürlich wieder
vielleicht trocken gefallen hat die
kommentare 0
weil ich bin 0 hier findet ihr die
eingeblendet wenn der ausblick könnte
mir einen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
dadurch verpasste keine videos mehr
laufen täglich auf meinen job
eingeblendet in dem mit merchandise
übrigens in ein paar tagen am 17.7
launchen da zwei neue artikel und hier
unten ist ein weiteres video verlinkt